monsieur le président nous avons demandé
la communication de la fiche de poste
concernant de votre travail et cela ne
nous a pas été adressées avez vous eu
connaissance de cette fiche de poste de
d'autre part monsieur le directeur de
cabinet nous a dit qu'il existait une
note de service relatives à vos missions
avez vous eu connaissance de ces deux
documents et pourriez vous nous les
communiquer puisque jusqu'à ce jour
personne n'a le les a communiqués tendue
alors la fiche de poste dont il est
question
simplement une note qui a été
communiquée quand vous êtes au cabinet
du président de la république vous avez
un certain nombre de choses à faire mais
votre périmètre délimité de manière très
claire et donc c'est une note de mémoire
qui était adressé par le directeur de
cabinet au secrétaire général de
l'elysée et qui lui indiqué que je
remplissais donc les quatre missions
dont vient visiter la 5e et s'étant
rajoutées par la suite mais je suis en
mesure de vous deux vous la fournir 100
points merci monsieur sur vous nous la
fournirai tout à fait je vous remercie
par rapport au déplacement et à la
protection très rapprochée du président
de la république et des épaules il
existe vous le savez entre les quatre
fonctionnaires qui assurent la
protection ultra rapprochée du président
une boucle de communication est-ce que
vous pouvez sous serment nous déclarer
que vous n'étiez pas dans cette boucle
alors pour être encore très précis
là-dessus
quand on est arrivé au palais de
l'élysée il n'était pas habituelle que
la chefferie de cabinet le service de
presse les photographes soit en réseau
radio donc quand vous êtes dans un bain
de foule quand vous êtes sur un
déplacement il ya énormément de
journalistes de monde
il faut vous appeler au téléphone il
faut vous cherchez à droite à gauche
donc on a eu sous l'impulsion de
françois xavier lorre l'idée de mettre
en place un système de télécommunication
système de radio pour ça qu'on peut voir
sur des images avec une oreillette
loriette n'étant pas réservée aux gardes
du corps et donc il y avait dans la
cette boucle là le service de presse la
chefferie de cabinet le photographe de
l'elysée est également le chef ou son
adjoint
du j'espère qu'ils étaient en
communication mais en aucun cas vous
n'aviez accès aux communications que
peuvent avoir entre eux sinon sur un
réseau sécurisé les officiers de
sécurité du gspr parce que ça aurait
interféré dans leurs fonctions et ce
n'était pas du tout le cas l'idée étant
de coordonner au mieux le déplacement du
président de la république de manière à
ce que les gens soient au bon endroit le
photographe au bon endroit le service de
presse m la presse au bon endroit et
qu'on puisse avancer de manière fluide
dans un déplacement qui se veulent
présidentielle donc de on doit
communiquer rapidement être pour être
efficace que jamais nous savons
absolument qu'existe ce réseau radio je
veux parler du réseau très spécial qui
est différent qui concerne les quelques
fonctionnaires qu'on peut compter sur
les doigts d'une main qui assurent la
protection rapprochée
pouvez vous donc que démentir ce qui a
pu être écrit dans un organe de presse
hier soir sur le fait que vous aviez
accès à ce réseau là pour le premier il
n'y a pas de doute mais pour le second
pouvez-vous déclaré sous serment que
vous n'avez jamais eu accès à ce dernier
alors pour être encore très précis nous
utilisons comme le j'espère avec le
service de presse le photographe de
l'elysée et la chefferie de cabinet
exactement le même appareil radio que le
j'espère simplement nous ne sommes pas
sur la même fréquence
vous n'avez pas la fréquence des
personnes du gspr qui assure la
nouveauté de ce nom alors je vais je
vais vous le dire de manière très claire
en plus c'est que au début ça a posé un
problème
cette idée de radio est ce que je
comprends d'ailleurs ce n'était pas
habituelle et donc le chef du j'espère
le colonel a décidé en accord avec le
chef de cabinet que nous n'avions accès
qu'à une boucle radio très limité donc
les quatre personnes dont on pouvait
parler c'est le chef de cabinet
l'attaché de presse présents le
photographe et le chef ou l'adjoint du
j'espère cite une autre une autre boucle
set c'était exactement je n'avais pas
accès à une boucle particulières de
sécurité
j'en ai pas connaissance je voulais vous
demander quel était votre fonction par
rapport aux déplacements privés du
président de la république
ceux ci étaient donc votre fonction si
j'entends bien ce que vous dites ne
relevait pas de la sécurité ou de la
police en conséquence vous n'étiez pas
armés